"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
DEMOCRATS CAN RUN, BUT THEY
CANNOT HIDE FROM JOE BIDEN'S
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
FREE-FOR-ALL.
PUBLIC DEMOCRATS IN SOME TOUGH
MIDTERM RACES ARE WAKING UP TO
THE REALITY THAT SWING VOTERS
MIGHT NOT BE SO KIND TO A PARTY
THAT CANNOT STOP POURING
GASOLINE ONTO THE INFLATION
FIRE.
THEY ARE REVOLTING AGAINST
BIDEN'S BAILOUT WITH SOME SHARP
REVIEWS, CALLING IT "OUT OF
TOUCH," AND SAYING THAT IT SENDS
THE WRONG MESSAGE.
EVEN THE LEFT-LEANING
"WASHINGTON POST" IS CALLING IT
A REGRESSIVE AND EXPENSIVE
MISTAKE.
THE WHITE HOUSE RESPONDING TO
ALL OF THAT AND DISMISSING
CONCERNS.
>> IF THIS IS ABOUT GETTING
PEOPLE TO VOTE AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS, THE REAL NATIONAL
EMERGENCY IS DEMOCRATS IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTION.
>> I DISAGREE WITH EVERYTHING
YOU JUST LAID OUT.
WE HAVE SAID WE AREN'T GOING TO
MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPY, SO IF YOU
ARE NOT MAKING EVERYBODY HAPPY,
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT WHAT YOU JUST
LAID OUT -- THAT CAN'T BE THE
CASE EITHER.
>> ONE DELUSIONAL DEMOCRAT IS
DOWNPLAYING ALL THE WARNING
SIGNS AND DD ABOUT THE LONG-TERM
PROSPECTS APPEARED >> HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT THE CHANCES OF THE
DEMOCRATS HOLDING ONTO THE
SENATE CUSTOMER >> I'M LIKING
IT.
>> BUT THE BIGGEST QUESTION MARK
IS HOW IT WILL BE PAID FOR.
TAXPAYERS ON THE HOOK FOR AS
MUCH AS $600 BILLION, BUT THE
WHITE HOUSE REFUSES TO TELL US A
PRICE TAG.
>> HOW MUCH DOES THIS COST?
SPEAK OF THE ARE STILL COMING
OUT.
IT MAY REMIND FOLKS --
>> SECRETARY, WHAT IS THE RANGE
OF POSSIBILITIES?
>> LIKE I SAID PROJECTIONS ARE
STILL COMING OUT BASED ON HOW
MANY PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT.
>> SO THERE YOU HAVE IT, THE
PRESIDENT HANDING OUT MONEY
BASED ON A PANDEMIC, EVERY DAY
HE SAYS THE ECONOMY IS GREAT,
AND EVERY DAY THEY SAY WE ARE
NOT IN A RECESSION, EVERY DAY
THEY SAY TITLE 42 IS NO LONGER
RELEVANT AND WE ARE GOING TO USE
IT.
WE AREN'T EVEN BUYING VACCINES
ANYMORE, SO ON WHAT BASIS DOES
THE PRESIDENT MAKE A DECISION
THAT YOUNG, HEALTHY, EDUCATED
PEOPLE WITH A LONG LIFE AND A
CAREER AHEAD OF THEM, ARE
ENTITLED TO THIS KIND OF REMEDY.
I'M LOOKING RIGHT AT YOU BRIAN.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU WANTED TO
DO IT.
I THINK HE WOULD'VE DONE IT 18
MONTHS AGO IF HE WANTED TO.
THE WORD BEHIND THE SCENES WAS
THE WHERE THEY GOT TO HIM, THAT
THIS IS A LEGACY BUILDER.
WE ARE GOING TO BUILD A LEGACY
SO THAT WHOEVER -- AND THEY SAY
"THIS WILL HELP TO FIND YOU."
HE KNEW THAT THIS WAS INHERENTLY
UNFAIR.
IT REMINDS ME OF WHAT HAROLD
FORD WAS SAYING LAST NIGHT, THAT
THIS $10,000, THE IMPACT IS
GOING TO MAKE WAS NECESSARY WITH
HIS OTHER PLAN THAT CAME
THROUGH.
I'M ALSO LAUGHING AT THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE ACTING AS IF NO
DEMOCRATS ARE AGAINST THIS.
YOU KEEP SAYING REPUBLICANS WITH
MITCH McCONNELL, BUT EXCUSE
ME, TIM RYAN, CHRIS MATHIS, THIS
SENATOR  --
THE HOUSE MEMBER FROM MAINE.
SHE RECE DAVIS FROM KANSAS?
THERE ARE MANY HIGH-PROFILE
DEMOCRATS WHO WANT NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS, AND NOW FOX'S SAYING
SAYING IT'S BETWEEN 500
-$800 BILLION.
>> THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
THAT IS WHETHER IT'S HALF A
TRILLION DOLLARS OR MORE, KOREA
JEAN-PIERRE INSISTS ON SAYING
"WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH IT'S
GOING TO COST."
HOW COULD THEY NOT KNOW?
ARE THEY THAT RECKLESS THAT THEY
WOULD REPORT OUR NATIONAL DEBT
EVEN HIGHER THAN A TRILLION
DOLLARS?"
>> SHE DOESN'T KNOW THAT IT'S
NOT IN THE BINDER, AND NO
WINDOWS, AND THEY DON'T CARE.
SHE SAYS THAT EXPERTS HAVE TOLD
THEM IT'S GOING TO BREAK EVEN.
EXPERTS HAVE NOT HAD A GOOD
TRACK RECORD THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
WHEN IS A REPORTER GOING TO SAY
WHICH EXPERT SAYS THAT?
WHO IS SHE GOING TO TROT OUT?
WILL YOU TRY JAY ILL?
THEY DON'T EXIST!
AND THEN, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS OUT
THERE SAYING "I HAVE THE POWER
TO DO THIS," LIKE HE IS AMERICA
ATROPHY HAS DAD.
LET'S CALL IT EVEN.
CAN'T DO THAT!
HIS FAMILY RAN THINGS!
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
THE BIDEN FAMILY, ALWAYS GETTING
SUSPICIOUS -- FROM DONORS, A
BANK GAVE HIM A NO INTEREST LOAN
FOR A HOME.
YOU CAN'T RUN A COUNTRY LIKE
THIS.
THEY ARE SAYING HE IS USING HIS
PANDEMIC POWERS.
WHEN IS IT OVER?
NEVER.
RUNNING THE REPUBLIC AS A KING,
AND IT'S NOT FAIR.
A REPUBLICAN GETS TO THE
PRESIDENCY, BUT YOU CANNOT
COMPETE AGAINST A KING WHEN
CONGRESS LETS HIM BE A KING.
USUALLY, YOU HAVE THE MIDDLE
CLASS, 50000-100000, NOW
TRUMP -- WITH THOSE MIDDLE-CLASS
VOTERS.
HE HAS NOW BETRAYED THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
YOU CANNOT JUST BAIL OUT GRAD
STUDENTS MAKING SIX FIGURES ON
THE BACKS OF MIDDLE CLASS
PEOPLE.
YOU CAN'T RATED THE TREASURY TO
PAY BRIBES.
WE USED TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLASS CONSCIOUSNESS.
MAY BE, HE GOT ROLLED BY THE
POLITICAL LEFT.
EVEN AS YOU SAID, THESE
DEMOCRATS AND COMPETITIVE RACES
THEY KNOW IT'S A WEDGE ISSUE.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK A QUESTION
THAT YOU ASKED YESTERDAY.
A YEAR AGO JOE BIDEN --
NANCY PELOSI, YOU SAID THEY
WEREN'T --
DOES THE HYBRID EDUCATION ACT
GIVE THEM DISABILITY?
I WILL SAY ONE MORE THING.
JASON SUGGESTED THAT IT WOULD
COST THE AVERAGE TAXPAYER
$2,000.
>> I THINK IT COULD BE HIGHER
THAN $500 BILLION, BECAUSE IT
DEPENDS ON THE INCOME THRESHOLD.
I ALSO DON'T THINK IT'S THE ONLY
TIME THAT HE WILL DO THIS, AND
THAT'S WHY AM HOPING THAT
SOMEBODY BRINGS A LAWSUIT.
I READ THIS ARTICLE TODAY THAT
SAYS THAT -- YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
TO SUE, BUT THE WAY THAT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION ACT READS IT'S
LIKE "WAIT, NONE OF US HAVE THIS
RIGHT" CUSTOMER CAN MOTHER THING
ON THE PANDEMIC LOANS, THOSE
WERE PASSED BY CONGRESS.
THEY HAVE PUT THEIR NAMES ON TWO
OF THESE.
THIS IS JOE BIDEN JUST SAYING "I
DO THIS WITH MY PEN."
THEY HAD TO LEAN ON THAT 9/11
AUTHORITY TO GET THIS DONE.
THAT WAS MORE MILITARY.
HAVING TO GO ALL THE WAY BACK
THERE, THE HERO ACT -- AOC IS
NOT A HERO IN THIS.
I KNOW SOMEBODY WHO LIVES IN
WYOMING WHO WAS AROUND HER SAME
AGE.
THIS HEAVY PIECE OF EQUIPMENT IS
USED FOR WORK AROUND THEIR
PROPERTY, AND THEY ALSO DO WORK
FOR OTHERS.
PAYS A LOT OF BILLS, IT'S REALLY
GREAT.
CAN'T TAKE OUT A LOAN, BUT --
WHY IS SHE MORE DESERVING OF
LOAN FORGIVENESS THAN YOU?
I WOULD LOVE TO ASK HER THAT,
AND HOPEFULLY, SHE WOULD HAVE AN
ANSWER.
THE LAST POINT IS ABOUT THE
WHITE HOUSE'S ANSWERS ON THIS.
-- WHO HAS THE AUTHORITY?
THEY SAY BY THE END OF THE YEAR,
IT'S GOING TO BE A WASH.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS A FREE
LUNCH.
IT'S COMING FROM YOU.
>> I SHARED MY VIEWS ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY.
I THINK YOU LOOK AT THIS IN TWO
WAYS: FAIRNESS AND INFLATION.
I THINK WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
FAIRNESS AROUND THE TABLE TODAY,
AND ON OTHER SHOWS ACROSS THE
NETWORK.
IF YOU PAID OFF YOUR DEBT A YEAR
AGO, WHY IS IT THAT WHEN THE
FAMILY SAVED AND MADE
SACRIFICES, IT'S UNFAIR TO THAT
FAMILY EVEN BY SEVERAL YEARS
AGO?
I THINK DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE TO
EXPLAIN THAT A BIT.
THIS -- FOR PROVIDING HELP.
TEACHERS, FAMILY DOCTORS,
NURSES, TRUCK DRIVERS,
ENGINEERS.
WE CAN GO DOWN THE LIST.
JESSE MADE THE POINT YESTERDAY
ABOUT -- CRITICIZED FOR TALKING
ABOUT OUR HISTORY.
THAT BEING SAID, WE WILL STILL
SHOW OFF THESE KINDS OF DOLLARS.
TO YOUR POINT YESTERDAY,
FINANCIALLY NEGOTIATED IN THAT
INFLATION REDUCTION, SO CONCERNS
ME IS THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
ARGUES YOU GIVE THESE KIDS AN
OPPORTUNITY, AND MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ARE AFFECTED BY THIS,
AND -- MANY HAVE THEIR DEBT
FORGIVEN ALL TOGETHER.
BUSINESSES CAN INVEST MORE IN
COMMUNITIES, BUY A HOME, INVEST
IN YOUR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION.
FINALLY, THE INFLATION PIECE --
OTHERS HAVE ALL TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
SOME PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE THE
SANCTIMONY OUT OF THIS.
I HAVE HEARD REPUBLICAN FRIENDS
IN CONGRESS BE REALLY CRITICAL
OF THIS.
I WOULD REMIND ALL OF US THAT
WHEN WE PASSED THE PPP LOANS,
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS HAD
FORGIVABLE LOANS UNDER THE LAW,
AND THAT WAS $2 TRILLION, AND
NOW SAYING THAT FLEXION WASN'T
CAULKED -- THAT INFLATION WAS
CAUSED BY SOME OF THIS.
>> DON'T YOU THINK IT'S
DIFFERENT?
ONE IS ELECTIVE, AND THE OTHER
IS A PANDEMIC THAT, THANKS TO
CHINA, DESTROYED THE COUNTRY.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
INFLATION.
I THINK THE SANCTIMONY NEEDS TO
BE REMOVED.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, AND UNLIKE
A LOT OF AMERICANS, THOSE LOANS
WERE FORGIVEN.
YOU CANNOT SAY INFLATION --
WHICH IT WILL, BUT I JUST WILL
NOT BE ON A HIGH HORSE ABOUT IT,
THAT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO INFLATION.
>> I THINK YOU ARE EATING APPLES
AND ORANGES AT THE SAME TIME.
>> BUT NOT WITH INFLATION, I
DON'T THINK SO.
WHAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS SIGNED,
JUST NEEDS TO TAKE A STEP BACK.
THE WHITE HOUSE, IF YOU THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO, YOU
WILL HAVE TO HAVE AN ANSWER OF
WHERE THIS MONEY COMES FROM.
>> MARCO RUBIO -- CUT THE
INTEREST RATE.
SOME OF THESE GO AS LOW AS 10%.
HOW DID THEY GET AWAY WITH THAT?
"PAY 5%, FOR THE NEXT YEAR, PAID
2%.
"TO ME, THAT MAKES MORE SENSE!
>> CONGRESS SHOULD DO IT.
YOU CANNOT JUST HAVE --
>> PELOSI WAS QUOTED A YEAR AGO
SAYING HE COULDN'T DO THIS.
>> BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT POLITICS.
THE OTHER THING IS IT'S PART OF
AN INSTITUTIONAL THING THEY ARE
DOING.
THE COLLEGES ARE RAISING THAT
MONEY, AND IT IS NOT LEVEL WITH
INFLATION IT'S LIKE AN
ENTERPRISE.
>> AS YOU SAID BEFORE, WHY NOT
PAIR THESE UNIVERSITY HEADS AND
EXPLAIN WHY TUITION COSTS HAVE
EXPANDED?
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE GETTING
FOR THIS INFLATION GAP,
STUDENTS?
NOT MUCH.
OUR HISTORY MAJORS, KIDS --
>> A FRIEND OF MINE HAS A KID
WITH A BUSINESS WITH TOOLS AND A
TRUCK, HAS TO BUY THE TOOLS
FIRST.
HE'S NOT GETTING ANY KIND OF A
BREAK.
DOESN'T MAKE MONEY IF HE DOESN'T
SELL HIS TOOLS.